there's a class for oppression that's  okay she seems peaceful my name is Aaron  Gilbert doctor of particle physics  that's step one everywhere by the way in  every crack very hard to wash off we  have dedicated our whole lives to  studying the paranormal now their  sightings all over the city there are  people out there that need our help  Boltzmann you're a brilliant engineer  Aaron no one's better at quantum physics  than you we can provide a real service  I'm joining the club you guys are really  smart about this science stuff but I  know New York and I can borrow a car  from my uncle disclose that the vehicle  was gonna be a hearse  let's go let's go oh did you want it  already so I like to Lau  someone is creating a device that  amplifies paranormal activity we might  be the only ones who can stop it oldsman  come on  the Hat is too much right is it the  wiggers that  here's a bigger picture and here these  ghosts can possess the human form  Oh